Well,
good morning, he and Jaramillo greet you
today, Tuesday, March 23, and here are the
most outstanding headlines of the day. Two
parents accused of the death of their
eight-year-old son appeared in court
this morning, León Gris, 27, and Christina
Grids, 28.  Both face
murder charges Police say the
parents called 911 Saturday
morning claiming their son had
attempted suicide Officers
found the boy unconscious
Detectives believe he was abused
Those over 16 with
pre-existing health conditions already  are eligible
to receive the
coronavirus vaccine there are several places where you
can schedule your appointment the tsja has been
located in north las vigas is
available in addition to carmen sean at the
convention center and the university
for more information on vaccines
and sites  that offer it visit
our page disney.com diagonal in
Spanish community leaders
started a new c  campaign returned
to life this is intended to raise
awareness of the importance of
the coronavirus vaccine within the
black community the clark county
health district and
state leaders are asking everyone to
get vaccinated they are also working to
remove any barriers to the
access to these now we pass with your
weather forecast temperatures are expected
below normal with a
maximum in the low 60s as well as more
wind return to the scholarships have a
good day I am this light mine and this
was your brief informative for news now
in Spanish
[Music]